when Amelia Clark took on the role of
Daenerys in Game of Thrones her life
changed forever in addition to quickly
gaining worldwide recognition she became
one of the highest paid actors on
television and received multiple Award
nominations all within a few short years
however only 23 years old at the time
and still early in her career Clark felt
blindsided by the nudity required from
her for the show Clark learned to stand
up for herself and become more
comfortable performing in nude scenes
she explained that as the show
progressed she felt more confident
standing up for her own privacy when 50
Shades of Gray came knocking at her door
with an offer to play the leading role
Clark told The Hollywood Reporter she
turned it down Without Regrets as she
didn't want another intensely nud role
to affect how the public saw her career